the plot for star wars the force awakens
is a tightly guarded secret but what we
now know is that the story it tells as
well as the overarching narrative for
the new trilogy is not what franchise
creator George Lucas originally had in
mind speaking with gamespot sister site
CBS News Lucas explains that the Star
Wars saga as he envisioned it is
basically a soap opera Disney listen to
Lucas ideas but wanted to go another
direction the issue was ultimately they
looked at the stories and they said we
want to make something for the fans I
said all I wanted to do was tell story
of what happened it started here and
went there it's all about generations
and the issues of fathers sons and
grandfathers it's a family soap opera
people don't realize it's actually a
soap opera and it's all about family
problems it's not about spaceships so
they decided they didn't want to use
those stories they decided they were
going to do their own thing so I decided
fine the force awakens is the first Star
Wars movie that Lucas will have no
direct hand in producing he says Disney
wasn't very thrilled about working with
Lucas on the movie and the visionary
admits that he wouldn't have been much
help considering his ideas clash with
Disney's he went on to compare his exit
from the juggernaut entertainment series
to a breakup when you break up with
somebody the first rule is no phone
calls he said the second rule you do not
go over to their house and drive by to
see what they're doing the third one is
you don't show up at their coffee shop
and say you're gonna burn it you just
say nope gone history I'm moving forward
the CBS News full interview with Lucas
will air on CBS this morning in December
the force awakens comes to theaters on
December eighteenth with great
expectations
you